pray for the Devil is a horror movie
about the first female Exorcist in seven
centuries I met up with the cast but
before the interview they gave me an
exorcism Encounter of my own
hello hi we feel strongly that if we
want this young girl to survive we must
perform the procedure here and now oh
that doesn't look good
they will use your pain and break into
your soul well they're gonna eat off me
cause I'm scared
[Applause]
laughs
uh first off thank you so much for
having me here today I'm a little bit
nervous I just went through an actual
exorcism yeah okay casual casual did you
guys do that experience you did okay
that I am frightened from doing that
what's it like filming a movie based
around multiple exorcisms not as scary
as that experience
what's the movie about
the movie is about a young woman who has
a calling to fight the devil and she
pushes past the boundaries that the
church puts in front of her
to save a young girl's Soul when it
comes to like Paranormal Activity and
exorcisms do you guys truly believe in
that so have you experienced anything
throughout your life
experienced some
ugly things but in terms of exorcisms I
don't know I think it's a
firmly believe it's a door you have to
open but once you open it you can't
close it and so I don't know you see
here keep that door shut it's fine with
me I believe I believe in I think I
believe in the Supernatural life well I
certainly believe that uh it's a
possibility right I just don't want to
experience like aliens I think they're
real they gotta be out there I don't
want to yeah I'll find out even though
that's cool
I'm still shaking from that pray for the
devil